kohlekraftwerk heute die filme alles ist
alles so weit dass das montags was dabei
rauskommt einatmen ganz ohne probleme
mein name ist conny wieland vom beruf
bin ich ergriff
angela merkel hat am ende ihrer
berufslaufbahn sehr viele fehler
begangen es wird zeit für was neues
[Musik]
neuer alles ganz entspannt und da werden
mal schauen wo wir heute noch ein paar
[Musik]
wir fahren jetzt nach seeburg bei halle
und
transportieren die schalung für ein
neubau
[Musik]
nämlich noch ein beifahrer
wir bewegen uns jetzt hier bei 1 euro 60
doch super wenn sie mobile guten 80 bis
90 cent was nur für der steuer drauf
geht das ist nicht mehr sinnvoll die
preise können nicht nur steigen die bahn
steigen
die grünen wollen schrittweise auch über
250 hochtreiben und da gehen die leute
noch wählen die grünen wählen haben
diese klatsche
natürlich sage ich wir als deutschland
müssen das entschuldigen dass der
klimawandel
die langsamer vorangeht oder ganz
gestoppt wird ist das erreichen mehr als
deutschland oder in der eu damit das
nicht alleine erreichen gleich um an
mächtig aber auch das ist alles
bezahlbar bleibt unsere regierung sorgt
nur dafür dass wir halt elektroautos
kaufen und batterien kommen hier die
kommen aus dritte welt wo sehr guter
stil und überall dort wo
kinder das abbauen das letzte was ich
eben wirklich gift ich es im kopf gehen
wenn darauf was auf basis ich denke das
ist er dazu gekommen
[Musik]
grieser grüne da bisher
meist
[Musik]
ich bin ein teil eines großen ganzen
wenn wir nicht mehr fahren würden egal
ob offen oder essen als würde unsere
wirtschaft machen
die kennen das auch alleine aber im
endeffekt
könnte ich ja alles verhalten und es
geht schneller und daher
viele hände schnelles ende
[Musik]
bürgerkraftwerk sollte man so lange da
lassen wie es nötig ist ich persönlich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass man jetzt
alle kohlekraftwerke am besten oder der
atomkraftwerke dass man alles vom netz
nehmen und wir heute strahlen die mit
sonnenenergie windenergie alles
bewirtschaften können dass wärme und
schaffen heute da die pillen alles ist
alles soweit das dass man das was dabei
rauskommen durch einatmen kann ohne
probleme von daher so ein treffer
diesmal vor zwanzig dreißig vierzig
jahren war
kraftwerk
[Musik]
kurios ist merkel jetzt
multi besuchen ich guck mal was gemacht
[Musik]
gute die grüße
scharmbeck gepackt
das ist weil es die war stressig und
ronny noch mehr stress was kann man da
bitte ich dich mal was zeigen
ich habe mir entwickelt das ist kein
track ich brauche neuen schrank für
meine schuhe und kommen wir aber nicht
weiter könntest du dir da helfen
das wäre sehr lust und zeit natürlich ja
natürlich wird das nicht gerne machen
mutti irgendwie zu helfen und zu machen
zu tun also wäre das nicht so gerne
macht wer sich das ist hier normaler
mensch
[Musik]
und wir wussten
natürlich gehe sehr gerne arbeiten ich
freue mich aber auf meine rente du bist
noch sowie personen die noch im
rentenalter die noch rente bekommen ich
glaube bei steyr mir jetzt dass ich
nicht mehr das dass das rennen leider so
weit angehoben ist am ende
dass sie habe es ja nicht mehr chef
trend zu werden so in die fairways ist
das bringen wir das wenn ich irgendwo im
pflegeheim liege
womöglich versorgt werde das
funktioniert ja aber im endeffekt
wende rente die ich noch habe das dafür
draufgeht aber dafür kann man als junger
mensch fonds offen
ob das sinnvoll ist obwohl die leute die
senioren das leben dann ja heute prüfung
mutter das motiviert noch mehr ausbilder
dass deutschland die darin arbeiten das
kann ich dich kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen kann ich nicht gutheißen
als wir werden die neue regierung kommt
wird dich mehr gerne wünschen dass wir
wirklich eine stabile rente haben und
heraus kommen haben jedoch ändern
[Musik]
also ich bin der journey wenn der beste
kumpel vom rennen und ging heute ein
bisschen bei seinem auto
kriegt es allein nicht so richtig hin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe festgestellt
dann sucht er
habe jetzt mal ein bisschen
ich denke man dass die dichtungen sein
wird
[Musik]
das wars
das hat alles
sie sind mir irgendwas wir erst mal
ein großes kreuz machen das kann das
muss
ja ein großes kreuz und
cdu wählen nicht sind grün nicht sind du
hast nicht eine partei wo alles super
jeder hat irgendwo dreck am stecken
mehr oder weniger immer hand das nicht
gewesen ich bin einfach der meinung dass
jeder der eine meinung hat und zurzeit
bildet sich jeder eine meinung es ist
auch unser entscheidender die dann auch
offiziell können zu tun und nicht auf
facebook oder auf instagram sondern halt
wirklich über dem wahlzettel wo wir was
verändern können
[Musik]
was mich eigentlich zurzeit tara prägt
das ist dass er alle ist blauem himmel
erzählen dass punkt ist beispielsweise
update wenn ich da bin ich die wurde
sodass sie haben hier nicht alles alles
definitiv nicht und die greifen auch zu
wenig probleme auf die für mich jetzt
wirklich relevant sind wie zb zweite
thema äußern und migration wie schlecht
und doch geht und weil sie nicht mir
geht es darum dass nicht schlecht ich
habe da kein problem nicht stirbt
niemand der in unser land rein kommt
weiß ich nicht ich finde das schwachsinn
da grundsätzlich dagegen zu sein
[Musik]
jetzt sehr guten freundin fand sie
dieses basieren und der die anlagen
drastisch auf noch die ich jetzt
besuchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was man machen könnte der größte
augenbrauen christian alder naja das ist
nach so einer langen zeit müssen wir mal
was machen
[Musik]
das war schon echt hat die fast volle
drei monate nicht zu arbeiten nicht zu
wissen wie es weitergeht wie ist damit
erhält das habe ich einfach nicht
gekommen
der lockt an sich war schön übertrieben
wir waren einmal über also einmal
überfordert definitiv
also in der zeit hat man sich sehr oft
alleingelassen geführt ich habe sehr oft
geweint weil ich einfach ich lebe meinen
traum und muss nach dem halbjahr auf
rechnung oder schließen weil es einfach
keine lösung für uns gab
[Applaus]
ich finds nicht tragbar für unseren
staat hierfür führt er an den ich das
nicht tragbar weil wir frauen nicht
[Applaus]
impfen lassen ja nein vielleicht - und
der schwebe wir haben gestand weise
medikamente die sonst wie viele jahre
brauchen bis die zugelassen werden weil
die langzeitstudien fehlen und hier ein
impfstoff der innerhalb von von allen
daher gestellt wurde wird gesagt okay da
als zugelassen als gewohnt statt da wird
passiert nichts weiß nicht ich bin seit
schlimm dass er die leute versuchen
dahin zu schieben so sollen sie doch
selber überlegen lassen ob es gerne
machen möchten oder nicht
renten-etfs das sind was sie noch
einmal frei soll 2000 gesellschaft und
das wird sich wohl sicherlich noch ein
bisschen weiter ziehen
[Musik]
ich wünsche mir auch schon beim
bundesregierung das alles bezahlbar
bleibt und dass die kleinen nicht
gebessert
[Musik]
wenn ihr noch mehr aufbringen generation
merkel sehen weil das hat einfach auf
der mediathek vorbei
[Musik]